Đại đầu của mình đó, mình có thể mấy cho một chứ là kinh thư,
bởi vì không xam mình là ai,
một câu đình nhỏ thỏa một câu đình hả đông,
và chắc có thể khoảng lý đằng này trong khi bạn này lưu lưu gỳ.
Đi mặc chiếm mong bạn, người dưới nhé trong nhau.
Bà này có tình cập, cất tiệt, cất tiệt, kiếm bạn này,
bởi bạn lưu lưu, có những cái gì vậy là,
không có ai vậy không?
Mặc tiểu an lúc ở dưới an lạc, khoảng lý đằng đợc.
Thế vần nhớ lần đầu tiên khiến đến gặp bàng này,
bàng đó hồi làm việc, ăn chỉ đến kưi và chào hỏi,
bàng đã chỉ nghĩ nó cũng một lần thế,
được cuối sống tịt của làm việc.
Bàng dần sau để ở ngày húng sau lại,
thì ăn khoái trở lại,
bởi vì lần đầu tiên em cập,
thì chứng bàng có bàng đó có lý cập phê,
trảm phê.
Thì lần sau đến lại,
cầm phê lý cập phê,
ăn công đi,
và chỉ là vệ bàng,
bụng vài lời với cập phê,
sau cập phê,
thì đến trục là,
không phải tưởng nhiều tưởng.
Cái khó các bạn nghĩ là,
lúc cũng bất tưởng là có thể
nó có một lâu hông rơi mà mình đã mụcu chắc,
nó ngoài biệt đã lúc.
Ná đã đi tới môi ăn một lý cà phê.
Bật kẻ ăn trong ngoài đình là chiếc.
Nàn trụ đồng,
thì mình nghĩ là em bàng mất đường,
thì tình thử mình,
và thì nên mắt ra vý đó,
em nghĩ có những cuộc có cho chiếc,
em nghĩ thân mắt ra vá sau đó,
em nghĩ mắt ra chiếc,
em tư tư, em là công đi,
đứt trảy đả nó,
thì qua tình đường cho nhỏ như vậy,
thì tư tư yếu bàng bật đường lãng,
em nghĩ không,
sau này bàng này chở thành lắm mục trong nghiệm,
em nghĩ là một những nghiệm viên,
em nghĩ tốt nhất của ăn.
Đừng quên,
lúc sẽ thêm về sức tận bỏ vô vô càst the first step,
mới nhất.